my name is Seth manikin I'm the director
of the communications forum thank you
all so much for coming out a couple of
announcements before we begin if you ask
questions and we hope that you do ask
questions please come up to one of the
microphones we would really appreciate
it if you would identify yourself we do
record these and we also keep
transcripts of them for the record and
so it's always nice to have your name we
also have a mailing list up here so if
you enjoy this and events like this
please sign up for our mailing list we
only have six events a year and we do
not send emails out for anything other
than our six events so this will not be
a mailing list that you will get a lot
of spam with we'd also like to thank
Radiesse who is a co-sponsor of
tonight's forum and has been a sponsor
of a lot of our forms over the last
couple of years ago sponsor without
their support we would not be able to do
this and without any further ado let me
introduce tonight's panel dr. Eric
Lander is the president and founding
director of the Broad Institute of MIT
and Harvard a professor of biology at
MIT and a professor of systems biology
at the Harvard Medical School dr. Lander
was a principal leader of the human
genome project and from 2009 to 2017 he
served as co-chair of PCAST the
President's Council of Advisors on
science and technology under Barack
Obama dr. Lander has won the MacArthur
found a fallow ship at the MacArthur
Foundation when the whole foundation the
breakthrough prize in life sciences the
Albany Prize in medicine and biological
research the Mendel medal of the
Genetics Society in the UK the award for
public understanding of science and
technology from Triple A s and the
Woodrow Wilson prize for public service
from Princeton University among many
many other awards dr. Maria Zuber is the
MIT vice president for research and the
EA Griswold professor of geophysics
dr. Zuber has been involved in more than
half a dozen NASA planetary missions and
as the principal investigator for the
Gravity Recovery and interior laboratory
or Grail became the first woman to lead
a NASA spacecraft mission in 2016 Zuber
was elected to a two-year term as the
chair of the National Science Board the
governing body of the National Science
Foundation and earlier this week she was
appointed to another six-year term on
the board at MIT dr. Zuber oversees
research administration and policy for
more than a dozen interdisciplinary
research laboratories and centers and
her many accolades include multiple nasa
group achievement towards the harry a
harry H Hess medal up from the American
Geophysical Union and the Carl Sagan
Memorial Award so thank you both for
joining us tonight I wanted to start
just sort of generally and ask you what
point to both of you realized that you
wanted to be a scientist or going to
science so science chose me I didn't so
there there are legends in my family
about me jumping up and down in my
playpen pointing at the television when
the Rockets were launching and and I I
wanted to be a scientist forever I
started building telescopes when I was
about six I taught myself optics i
ground my own lenses and and all I ever
wanted to do was study space and and I'm
still doing it right Wow it's working
and so you really knew it at age six or
seven that that's what you wanted to do
that's incredible how about you Eric I
can't get over the grind
Wow shut myself down if I worked at him
right so nothing like that okay so I I
wasn't interested in science when
I was growing up I was interested in
math right so I did my undergraduate
degree in my PhD in pure mathematics and
I fell in love with math and high school
I was in New York kid I was lucky enough
to go to Stuyvesant High School and
found the math team and so I fell in
love with mathematics was walking after
Columbia University had a New York City
wide science honours program and I could
take the train up the Columbia on
weekends and learn about Galois theory
and other things and then went to you
know onward to math until after getting
my PhD in math I realized I didn't want
to do math as a career I just loved it
because math was very monastic and it
really wasn't it wasn't as in the world
and so I cast about for a number of
years and through a long series of
accidents fell in love with biology in
particular genetics so the last genetics
course I took for the best biology
course I took for a grade was sophomore
year of high school so I have no idea
but in any case it means that I'm
actually unqualified for my heart but I
have tenure so it's too late right so
you know but I did the one thing I have
in common when Maria was my mom let me
stay home whenever they launched the
rocket so I watched all the NASA
launches and this was like really
inspiring and transformative to feel
like that was going on that change was
happening though you know I've never
thought about working in space or
leading a space mission in the 60s that
was really it was amazing and and now
that both of you are if you're in charge
of research here you're running a big
Institute how do you miss the sort of
day-to-day doing doing bench work
overseeing your own experiments not
needing to oversee big teams of people
so I'm I don't think we've given up
doing research
but I assume your other responsibilities
also take up it well they take up time
yeah yeah
well yes so I've obviously Shrunk my
research group a fair amount and I have
more postdocs now than graduate students
but I share I share my graduate students
with another professor make sure and
then then we always have a bunch of
undergrads kind of running around doing
really useful things that we team up
with with the graduate students and the
postdocs oh so I am I you know there are
some days that are better than others
when when I prefer that I would have
would be in the lab but but you know for
me right now at this stage of my career
it's all about impact and and you know
after running big space missions I want
to have more impact than I had before so
helping and that's hard when you've run
a whole so so helping other people
create things and make things happen and
so every you know every faculty member
we hire here they have a dream and just
like we all have a dream and and usually
there's something holding people back
from achieving that dream okay it could
be that they need a lab renovation or
they need a piece of equipment or maybe
they just need to meet the right
collaborator and and so I actually get a
lot of satisfaction out of removing
barriers or creating opportunities to
allow others to achieve their dreams
because so then great things inevitably
happen at some point and and I you know
I feel like I played a really small part
in that but it's a it's a rush yeah
say yes just you know because you know
your experience running space missions
you know mind working on the human
genome project you want to have impact
comparable to the impact you've had and
at a place like MIT or Road Institute of
MIT and Harvard there's just all these
amazing people
all these amazing projects and so while
you have less time for your own research
hey you're still mentoring I mean I
think I feel like I know Maria feels
like we're mentoring colleagues or
mentoring faculty Rae during projects
and there's there's a satisfaction and
joy in that at the same time we still do
research the paper accepted to sell on
Monday and now evaluations we got yeah
we got to cut 40,000 characters out of
the damn thing now so you know you can
institution but you also have to worry
about you know red pen swing this thing
that the word length and it's it's I
think really great around MIT that the
people who played leadership roles still
continue to do science right because it
keeps you well actually it's it's it's
acceptable yeah so I mean you know it's
um you know what I would I lose in
administrative effectiveness or
efficiency because I'm still carrying on
you know a research program granted a
smaller one you know I I feel like I'm
more than make up for in having the
continued respect of my colleagues that
that I haven't given up I just go to the
dark side alright I wanted to sort of
broadly define this term the miracle
machine which we're using to to connote
the u.s. is technological and scientific
dominance and in the 20th century what
do you see as the ingredients that sort
of led to that why was the u.s. such a
leader in the 20th century why don't you
start with that sure let's start with
what what is this this miracle mission
the idea that basic research is so
powerful at producing useful things it's
not obvious right I mean even to this
day many institutions many countries
think if you want something useful you
should try to make something useful
Applied Research slide research and the
idea that really in this country comes
in many ways out of an eva bush in after
world war two that research should not
be done in government laboratories
exclusively or even primarily but should
be done in universities and distributed
research centers and funded by the
government and funded by the government
that you know in this this famous report
science the infinite frontier
you know the neither bush to president
roosevelt lays out a post-war strategy
right that frankly isn't obvious even
coming out of World War two when you
have Los Alamos and other things and he
says you know all that's good but after
World War two this is the way to have
the greatest impact is to place funds
around the country and to have people
compete based on proposals and ideas and
grants it's not central planning it's
like central laboratories well that's
the first real ingredient to this
miracle machine is you engage ideas all
around the country and you do it with
students which is another part of the
amazing thing why should you do research
with people who aren't like yet trained
and qualified right a nutty if you were
you know most businesses wouldn't run
their business with people who don't
like aren't fully qualified right and
yet the magic of doing research with
with students who are still learning is
brilliant because you get freshness of
ideas the staleness that sets in if you
have just hermetically sealed yourself
in something rather than having this
flow of young people and ideas and your
training their benefit and your trip and
your training the bench because those
people were going off to populate
companies all day that's another
brilliant part that wasn't obvious then
of course the the interaction between
the Academy and Industry and government
this is threefold this this triangle
here the connection to
industry flow these students flowing out
ideas flowing out IP flowing out to be
able to provide benefit to a society and
this virtuous cycle right that comes
from the government gets money from the
prosperity the prosperity is used to
fund back basic research and then of
course you have had brilliant investment
in the government sector you know most
famously a DARPA right folks who are
willing to say I'm not just interested
in building tomorrow's missile or a
plane but that we too have to be asking
long-term questions and being willing to
fund that so you know it's it seems
obvious we take for granted the system
that we have but it's a very odd system
almost all of its assumptions would not
have seemed obvious to people and it was
not what most countries in the world
we're doing and eventually when we've
seen everything that's come from this
virtuous system other countries have
said yes we should be doing it but it's
kind of wacky and we were they we were
like and in many case still are the the
best attractor of talent in the world
the most the most talented people in the
world wanted to come and be a part of
this and and so it it spoke for itself
it helped a great deal that when there
were a lot of people who were refugees
we took him in right as America has
always been that magnet to draw people
from anywhere right and NASA how did you
see that interplay between basic
research on a decentralized level then
funnel into actual applied science
projects sending people up in space like
I mean I can give you just an example or
please from my from my own research ok
so I I came out of I got my PhD at the
time when Ronald Reagan was president
and and so at that time there was a
great investment in space-based lasers
for Star Wars or Star Wars for a
ballistic missile defense and
and I said to myself yummy it was brand
new technologies but it was based on
fundamental physics of how laser systems
worked okay and they were moving to
solid state lasers as opposed to old
older designs that use flash lamps which
some of you in here may be familiar with
and flash lapse didn't last too long and
and they were a high power and and so so
I said to myself you know if we're
investing hundreds of millions of
dollars into laser tag I betcha there's
something I can do science with okay and
so I I was at NASA so I was able to get
my clearance and look at the technology
that these lasers were being used and
you know it was all classified but in
laser work you know the classification
is the energy of the laser and the
pointing of the how well you can point
it and the stability so so myself and a
handful of other people that were kind
of my age just out of school we we just
took all those specs and just dialed
them down until they were unclassified
and then turned out NASA was was
planning on sending a mission to Mars
and it was supposed to launch on the
space shuttle but the Space Shuttle blew
up so they had to find another launch
vehicle for the spacecraft it delayed
they threw several instruments out so
they opened up a competition for a new
altimeter and and so myself and my
buddies we proposed this laser system
and with with saying well we will never
ever be selected on this but we're gonna
go in there and we are gonna just kill
this competition so that when we grow up
they will remember us so our performance
beat the pants off of everything else we
got and you know were competitively
selected to send an insert
to Mars it was my second year out of
grad school Wow
so and it was because I was using
technology that was based on that was
advanced because of fundamental science
about solid-state lasers right and and
so I mean that's obviously that wasn't
my plan and it wasn't the DoD's plan
wasn't idea or die's plan to give you
the know hanging around right turning
the dials right well so we we see the
the fruits of the miracle machine every
day I just wanted to sort of for a frame
of reference talk about some of what we
mean by that so what are some of the
what are some of the inventions that we
use everyday that came out of this basic
research to applied research sort of
engine in the 20th century they go all
the way from GPS example do we take for
granted on cell phones well if you know
it comes in a lot of different ways but
yes in some ways it comes out of DARPA
in some ways it comes out of I think GPS
tracks back to when Sputnik was launched
and two folks at the University of
Maryland or Johns Hopkins or somewhere
we're trying to figure out how to locate
it and they were you know ad hoc write
him up with the idea of positioning in
the way of having multiple signals right
in a week they sort of figured this out
but then of course you needed relativity
to get an accurate signal Chris's time
dilation up there and and then
eventually it gets turned into a system
so it's it's this melange of different
things yeah the internet right you know
this crazy mix of computer science
places like here in Cambridge Carnegie
Mellon and on the west coast meeting
with Alec and the stories you know
intertwine
some threads say the survivability of
computer networks wanting to act to have
things that were survivable and right
therefore very distributed but but then
a government saying we're gonna invest
in this thing but isn't obviously very
useful yet right you know passing
messages back in short emails back up
but you know that exploits or an awful
lot of biotechnology when you think
about salvador luria here at MIT you
know and his work on this wacky
phenomena about how certain bacteria can
restrict certain viruses anyway gives
rise to restriction enzymes eventually
which are one of the key tools of
recombinant DNA and you know nobody set
out to say oh we're gonna have a
biomedical revolution recombinant DNA
they set out to say how-do had a
bacteria managed to copy their DNA how
do they manage to fix it they collected
just all the tools nature uses and then
at some point they said oh we could
start putting this together
right so if anybody had said please
build the following for us you know in
in some top-down fashion we would have
never gotten any of these these things
right I should adopt them right so
that's to me the the heart of the
miracle machine is most of these
remarkable things we we count on was not
somebody's you know central five-year
plan right something that emerged from
by accident or accident because but it
didn't from a direct path it emerged
from funding fundamental curiosity and
then being willing to run with it I
think the applied is important but it
was that combination it was not trying
to force something into a fully working
mode it was to let each stage begin to
tell you what it was good for right
right yeah and I you know just to add to
that get into the the people part of it
a little bit you know a lot of the
precision machining and the measurements
that were made to send things into space
you know spaces space is very
unforgiving and and so you know so
you've you've got to have everything
perfectly correct right I mean you have
an actuator you can't have any play in
it great I mean and you know not all the
people that go through this training to
do this wind up staying in the field and
doing that for a living what they work
their thesis on right but you would want
to you know if you had a company you
would want to hire a person that could
machine something to that tolerance
right and create something or do the
corrections on something to get down to
nano levels so you had you had the the
interplay between research and industry
and this sort of diffuse sense that when
you have people working to that degree
of expertise and and and specificity
even if that's not precisely what
they're gonna be working on an industry
you're gonna want those people that's
right right right
and when I think back over sort of our
society's relationship with science in
the 20th century my my sort of vision of
it in my head is that obviously we had
the the detonation of the a-bomb at the
end of World War two but for a lot of
the 20th century the sort of our general
view was that science was a force for
sort of an unalloyed force for progress
and good and was going to lead us into
the into the future would you say that
that's my impression of that is correct
well it's not whether it is true but
whether that was the that was the sort
of zeitgeist well I would I would agree
with that right okay Star Trek I was
brought up on a ridge '''l Star Trek and
you know you had this amazingly diverse
crew you know the Russians and the
Americans were you know Jensen checkoff
was working with everybody else it's
great even even had you know Spock from
another species through species right it
was
you know I was that was the optimistic
view of the future right and it was
gonna bring us all closer together
accept each other that was what I was
brought up on in the sixties right right
and that we were gonna you know explore
discover right and certainly you know
NASA sort of embodies that that sense of
there's this endless mystery and we're
gonna go and learn about it and and so
we've talked about this a little bit now
we're a couple of decades into the 21st
century and I think that there's more
concern about whether these these
inventions and whether all of this
progress is necessarily going to be used
for good we've talked about you know you
have autonomous cars in the one hand and
the spectra of autonomous weapons on the
other you know social media is something
that can connect us and bring us
together it's also something that can
disseminate hate speech or
misinformation is that sense that we
need to pay attention to the
implications of science and the
implications of research is that
something that has cropped up sort of in
in a forward way more recently or is
that science is just copy me so
incredibly useful right we didn't worry
about spreading misinformation on the
internet before we had an internet right
the Internet is pervasive and now we can
also see the ways it can be misused it's
that question of you know will
technology be used for good or for bad I
think we now have a sophisticated
understanding that all of these
technologies are gonna require
responsible behavior it's gonna require
responsible management bio technologies
genome editing gene drives to change
nature well you know gene drives maybe
it's a way to get rid of malaria right
Jeanne drives maybe it's a way to screw
up our environments completely right you
know and and both can be true and so and
I can go down and maybe we will go down
a list of all of these things there are
enormous positive returns that could be
had but if we can't as responsible
scientists also say there are a lot of
potential misuses bio technologies that
allow you to pend potentially design
cancer-killing
uncle lytic viruses it's the same bio
technologies that could let you design a
bio weapon someday so it's it's more the
question of the governance that's needed
the norms that are needed how we run a
world that's going to get the benefits
while knowing full well that if we don't
do this responsibly we're gonna get
potential dystopias associated with it
right so it's just I think a grown up
technology we better take seriously and
yeah we we think about this a lot you
know I mean so I mean at MIT our ethos
is you know we want to make a better
world so we want to help people and you
know so the idea out there that we're
creating a I write that that's gonna put
people out of work and they're not gonna
have jobs this is let me tell you this
is very worrisome to our researchers who
say no like we you know we we have to
create the future we're how do we figure
out how people can work with robots you
know how do we how do we create the new
jobs and and so there's there's actually
a huge amount of effort going on on
campus now trying to try to think these
issues through in many sectors about you
know trying to consider the ethical
considerations in parallel right as
we're making these discoveries I think
you know not waiting until you know we
get to a certain point but you know
thinking about it at the same time right
maybe a little bit of a cultural
difference in East Coast and West Coast
everything is a generalization but on
the west coast there's maybe a little
more
of the techno optimism right whatever
problem you have technology will solve
that problem and I think I'm not sure
that that's enough answer problems will
arise that aren't necessarily solved by
technology they are gonna take us
understanding that technology can go
wrong what I frankly love about the
community is that people feel like it's
really here is that people feel that
it's their responsibility to make sure
the technology doesn't get used to all
right I guess my question is whether
that notion of there being a parallel
ethical responsibility is something that
has been sort of more developed and more
pronounced recently and and I think of a
parallel in journalism in that kind of
in American journalism the history of
American journalism dissents always was
our job is to put out information and
we'll let people decide we're not
supposed to come down on one side or
another and the journalistic community
has realized over the last several
decades that actually when you're
dealing with things that are true and
not true it's not acceptable to just put
it out there and there's been a sort of
grappling with this need to have ethical
guidelines as well my my sense is that
there has been a similar thing that has
happened in science but maybe it's been
there no well I you know there's
certainly a lot more discussion of it
lately and I mean Ithaca considerations
and then I would also say what's been
going on for kind of a longer time has
been the the idea of the students coming
in whatever they work on they're really
committed to leaving this world a better
place than the world that they came in
to okay and and what not what I
attributed this to in part is you know
the kids come in and you know starting
in first or second grade they all do
community service right and we're and
the the ones that are really motivated
they stick with it and they they find
something passionate in that and they
carry it with them so even
there you know they could be a
mathematician right where you know you
would go to a grad school because I want
to solve this problem right but now they
want to solve this problem so that they
can help somebody or you know I want to
open up you know the you know reduce
darkness in the universe by you know
understanding how this works and you
know there's much more of a commitment
to to really improving the human
condition so I'll give you actually an
interesting example we have you might be
familiar with fact we have a a fusion
startup that came out of MIT the plasma
science and fusion lab and and these
these folks they're using high field
superconducting magnets and actually
hope to make a fusion power plant that's
about the size of this room okay and and
as opposed to a big experiment that's
being done in Europe that's the size of
a football field so and the motivation
for for these folks they they they don't
want to be billionaires mm-hmm they
don't want to win a Nobel Prize they
started doing this because they're
really really concerned about climate
change and their there is just the there
it's just an absolute sense among them
that they have to get on with this and
this has to be done and we have to do it
now and that's why they want to do it
mission I think there's a strong sense
and this generation particularly they
the students now of mission as the
driving force and and that's different
from earlier generations
there's always elements of it we're
talking about the proportion of it right
I think I think you hear much more
concerned about mission as a driving
force in life then say a generation or
two earlier and do you think that's
because there's a greater sense of the
precariousness of our situation now or
is there another is it because now you
have community service sort of being
built into curriculum
starting in elementary school I don't
know maybe maybe it's because the world
is able to communicate such you know so
much better you know from from the time
we observed the world that they well the
world that they grow up in I mean they
see arts of the world I mean you know if
you grew up and you were in a privileged
existence you wouldn't have seen the
whole you know people in other parts of
the world that that didn't you know have
the same you know all the things that
you had but I think from you know
certainly from the time that you know an
Apollo 8 when we first got the view of
you know earth rise over the moon and we
saw the earth as a you know fragile
place it you know it got a lot of people
thinking and and now you know kids
growing up can see others in poverty or
state see things I mean I grew up in an
coal mining town
eastern Pennsylvania an anthracite
country and where my father was a
policeman and he had one of the highest
paying jobs in town and so but I I
didn't think I was poor because I you
know in the area where I grew up in you
know everybody was kind of the same but
you know then you go other places and
you see what other people grew up with
in their situations and you know it it
really affects you so I just think that
they be the the way that we see so much
of the world now you know really does
impact people right I'm curious you
mentioned this sort of East Coast West
Coast divide and that is a little bit of
a balance why do you think that is
because clearly there it's not like
people are raised in the West Coast go
to school in the West Coast then go and
work in Silicon Valley you have MIT has
a large community over working in the
tech industry is that just because of
the accumulation of wealth and the tech
sector over the last couple of decades
or
I don't know I think I think it's a many
many different things and I'm not sure
I'm enough of a cultural anthropologist
to really diagnose it it's more just
when I have dinners with people on the
west coast versus on the East Coast
proportion of people who feel like
technology will work it all out it's
just much higher that they're really
good that it couldn't go wrong right I
think I think the West Coast is still
grappling with the idea that social
media doesn't necessarily just unite
everybody happily that there are some
downsides to right so it may also be the
fact that in some ways the institutions
on the East Coast are a little a little
more rooted in the humanities and
humanism and things that balance it in a
certain way it takes some historical
perspective recognize that most things
run into problems at some point in their
life cycle and you might as well plan on
the fact that it's gonna run into
problems right that's at some point so
it's you know this isn't the
black-and-white sort of thing it's just
it's just that I detect more folks in
conversations around here recognizing
that to fulfill the dreams for
technology creating startups is a great
thing and it's not gonna be enough
because there are things that can't be
done by the company there are things
that have to be done by a society
because it's not in the interest of a
company appropriately and we've got to
have multiple low you know low sigh of
responsibility right so I think there's
more discussion about roles of
government roles and responsibilities I
think there's you know that kind of
idealism to be willing to start things
that won't maximize profit total
maximize mission but again I don't wanna
oversell this as you know this is the
distinction between right but I think I
think it's very important that these
communities have slightly different sets
of experiences and and I'm just struck
that you know it's great we have a
diverse country and the approaches but
of course there's a lot of the country
that is left out of the tech revolutions
entirely we have we have spots like
Pittsburgh with Carnegie Mellon where
you really have a Tech Center with jobs
growing around that industries going
around it but we should be as worried
about the fact that the the fruits of
technology and the sense of agency that
you can change things it's not uniformly
distributed around the country you know
are we least yeah yeah it's a very non I
understate for exaggeration this can't
be a good thing for the country in the
long run right we have simply
concentrations on the coast plot on the
coasts you know plus Carnegie Mellon
plus one or two other places or
something rare right yeah I mean new
jobs new jobs are gonna be created by
the tech industry I mean you know
technology and scientific advances are
gonna provide a basis for new knowledge
that smart people are gonna come in and
figure out really interesting and in
some cases lucrative things that could
be done but you know unless we think
about how those being displaced from the
jobs that they have you know can benefit
from the new economy we're just not
gonna have a stable society to anybody's
benefit there's I think a period in the
90s and early 2000s when we said average
income is going up right but maybe it's
not it's not enough to look at the
average it might be the distribution is
also really important right right yeah
you say maybe we won't have a stable
Society it sort of feels like over the
last couple of years that we might
already be inching towards that place
where there's such a divide that there
are really deep divisions and it's
unclear how we move past that and
whether technology and the technology
sector is engaged in ways that can help
us move past that well we're you know
we're so in the I received the climate
action plan
one of one of the things that that we've
done is we're thinking a lot about you
know let's not just preach to the choir
okay so people people who understand you
know that climate change is a real
problem it's great that they understand
that but if we're only speaking to them
right so let's let's let's figure out
who the messenger ought to be right okay
so so we've you know we actually got
some of our social scientists and
political scientists involved in doing
some polling and understanding what you
know what what kind of messages would
people accept and and who should the
messenger be so so you know the word
climate change some is a you know it's
it's a third rail and you can't use that
but but you know people are feeling the
impacts of changes that are going on so
so you can talk about extreme weather
and you can talk about change and and
and the messenger shouldn't necessarily
be some smart person from MIT saying
come on guys they're probably certainly
but but it you know it it it could be
their children right you know who who
understands you know better of what's
going on community leaders are great
messengers those in religious life are
grounded in the you know respected in
the community so the these are the kinds
of people that need to get engaged in
this kind of messaging it makes me think
of Pittsburgh when Pittsburgh air was so
thick and dirty there was a period I
don't remember exactly when but they
invented the air quality index and then
air pollution became less abstract it
became the air quality index in this
city today is whoa or terrible or
whatever and it made it it made it
real and kind of measurable and you
started hearing it on the radio and it
led to cleanup of air because there were
ways to describe it and so it may be
that these communications things are
ways ways to encapsulate things in ways
that connect for people the extreme
events I think are some of the best yeah
and you know this is a communications
forum yeah communicating in a simple
straightforward way you know that you
know instead of us being like twins and
only talking to each other and no one
can understand us we have to figure out
ways to communicate right yeah and
usually talking about what's gonna
happen 200 years from now it's not it's
not that way right right so you both
have been in an advisory roles
scientific advisory roles on a federal
level have gotten to look at a wide
variety of issues what keeps you up at
night in terms of the areas of science
that where we are not fully grappling
with the potential implications or need
to very quickly grapple with them well I
you know the federal budget for the last
couple of years has has actually been
better in terms of funding of science
correct right yeah and so it's no but
nobody in really in either party really
like sequestration and they never
thought that sequestration was going to
happen and then when it did happen they
they didn't really like it and so the
the budgets have been okay but but in
terms of buying power they're they're
down and I I worry about I worry about
the level of investment that the u.s. is
making relative to the level investment
that other parts of the country are
making and other parts of the world the
other parts of the world are making and
and so you know other now of course
other countries they have read our
playbook and and they realize that
investing in science you know means that
you're gonna get higher educate you know
educated people who can start companies
and you know innovation is starting to
grow in other places so the the share of
the pie so to speak in in terms of
discovery is going to be more
distributed so it's it's not going to be
fully US dominated but of course the
United States can benefit from
discoveries in other places you know
just like others have benefited from
things that we have discovered but but I
do think it's important for us to stay
in the forefront on things I've one area
where I actually have particular concern
is is that the biotech industry actually
and and so you know so that's how many
billions per year does the the biotech
industry contribute to the the US
economy and and because of privacy
considerations we have limits in terms
of the kind of data that we can collect
on people and how we use that data where
as in some other countries notably China
the government takes all that data and
so if we're thinking about personalized
medicine and personalized treatments and
you've got a really big database of
personal data and over here you have a
smaller database you know that leads to
to a mismatch so that that to me is one
concern I have it's interesting it's a
the the biotechs of topic I of course
think a bunch about it's possibly the
case that in biotech and in medicine
were it's not a question of privacy it's
it's it's our inability to share data is
as much technical right now that we
haven't forced the healthcare system to
be a learning system so one of I feel
our great failures in the
the President's Council advisers on
science and technology in 2009 was when
the American Recovery and Reinvestment
Act assigned 40 billion dollars to
electronic medical records we wrote a
report that said the federal standards
receiving those monies called the
meaningful use standards shouldn't
require that the system be interoperable
in order to get the reimbursement but it
never happens because industry managed
to say if that word required planes
would fall out of the sky patients would
die patients dying because it wasn't in
many ways it has been the reverse so we
we backed ourselves into a system that
is more vulcanized than ever and don't
require universal exchange languages
because what I do know from other
projects we've started around here in
Boston that when you ask patients they
want to share their data yeah so the
reason I say I'm not I I would not even
say privacy is the biggest problem most
patients 90 plus percent of the patients
think we are sharing the data and
learning from it they actually want us
to have this medical system and we don't
I think we got to really move to a world
or her health care system is a learning
system powered by all the patients who
check the box and say I wish my
anonymous data to be used now the place
where I think your argument applies you
know he was much more force is in in a
bunch of other areas where I think the
broad point you're making which is very
large AI databases are gonna be very
small area databases applies all over
the place this is certainly true in
facial recognition technology as many
other technologies so I actually broadly
agree with the point voice recognition
almost any of those sort of things I
wanted to put in this special you know
argument for our failure to get this
other technological barrier that that is
blocking us but I think your point is
absolutely right the scale of investment
going on in China
right now is gonna allow AI to simply be
better and more robust and then there's
another scale of investment which i
think is as consequential which is in
STEM education
I worry greatly that the investments
that as a country I mean at the high end
of the distribution MIT Wow the
opportunities are better in the world
but if you take the median students in
the United States and their opportunity
in STEM education I worry about that
investment too so I mean there's a lot
of choices
I'd say yeah I mean look at you know
FIRST robotics competitions you know we
we fill high school gyms yeah and you
know in China they're filling stadiums
and so actually the only way for us to
continue to compete with that is is to
continue immigration and bringing in as
much talent as we can so now we see more
frequently that that talent is coming
and then leaving well yeah maybe they
don't always feel welcome right yeah so
so the those those are concerns about
how the US the u.s. is role on a sort of
world stage what about kind of more meta
concerns that the areas where we might
not be fully considering that the
ethical implications of research are
there like you know Elon Musk is has
talked at great length about how AI
keeps him up at night because he's
convinced that we're gonna have killer
ai's that seems a little bit far-fetched
to me but are there areas where you're
concerned that we're not fully grappling
with and considering the ethical
implications of the research that we're
doing who's we
we the scientific community you we is
report the scientific community in it
you know scientists and let's not worry
about whether we are considering it or
not let's worry about when we consider
it it's still hard
right so take climate change I got
friends who say we've got to do
geoengineering because we got a real
problem if we don't Geoengineer the
planet to change the albedo and bounce
we're screwed yeah we may have some
events that occurred that we can't
recover from other people good friends
mind here also I'm I'm kind of ignorant
but I like engaging this conversation to
say are you out of your mind
do you have any idea what might happen
with a to engineering gone wrong so they
view that as unethical to do to consider
no nobody will go so far if you put it
in the form of is it unethical to think
about it that would be but it would be
irresponsible to go do that with
anything like what we've got
I think the point these are hard things
almost always they're hard trade-offs
what I talk about you know all of the
bioengineering that can be applied to
human health and that there's no bright
line that separates it from the bio
engineering that could make bio weapons
when I look at the AI that can be used
to oh I don't know to predict suicide
risk and help to suicide prevention it's
also AI that can be misused to go decide
the hole should be sentenced to longer
terms in jail but it ends up you know
engaging lots of discriminatory
information in it the problem is these
aren't simple lines to draw all of these
are hard things to struggle with and now
you're questioning to be are we
struggling with it exactly and but
that's enough and of course we're not
struggling with it enough they're
daunting problems we need to we need to
teach hard about it we need to think
hard we need to make it exciting for
students to be able to engage in it and
think about solutions we haven't thought
of and they can't just be students of
science engineering they're gonna be
students who bring in the whole range of
human disciplines if we're not
struggling with those questions enough
what can we do to incentivize both
scientists were now at the pinnacle of
their careers and also scientists were
up through their careers how can we
change that culture we could have MIT
communications forms that discuss right
this this will in fact change the
culture of science well it'll help would
we we have had a discussion like this
even five years ago that you think that
this discussion wouldn't have this
wasn't as much of a topic of
conversation
it certainly was just no I certainly
wasn't asked it's come up much more you
know we did a panel together ash Carter
you know I was moderating where there's
been on the panel but Maria and ash with
the panelists on similar topics I think
it is something we're feeling it's just
the responsibility of this age it's
becoming clearer and clearer and I mean
the the faculty Institute they're asking
for it right there they're asking for
these discussions to take place and and
so because what we what I think what we
don't want to have happen is to have
some pronouncement come down that all
right no you don't work on this kind of
AI right and you know our faculty and
our researchers they want to be aware of
what the issues are and and have
conversations with their colleagues and
decide for themselves what's the right
thing to do and they and and then when
asked about it they they want to say
I've thought about it and have a good
answer I mean it's sort of everything we
do around here so I I assume that any
decision that I make here at MIT that
I'm gonna get hauled before Congress and
have to explain it okay and and it's
happened so don't think that this is I'm
just making this up but I mean it
doesn't mean that that that we
necessarily take the safest path just
because I don't want to get skewered
right but but it means that you want to
think it through and get asked the
question and say no we've we've thought
about it and and here's where we're
coming down on it
so obviously you don't want a
pronouncement saying do this research
don't do that research what about a
pronouncement saying to do research
there has to be you there has to be in
proposals and ethical component a
discussion of the ethics of how this
research is going to play out about
integrating that into I wouldn't you
embarrass me once you make it the
requirement that the grant proposal
contain a section on that I'm granting
agencies wanted to fit but you'll have
checked that box
that can't be a Dolf sure do it but it
happy enough and it almost you know
risks alienating people because if it
becomes you have to have promised that
you have thought about the epic so and
have an emphasis on the proposal right
it's got to be much more vibrant than
that we've got to actually argue about
this stuff but is there a way to make it
organic and vibrant and also ensure that
those discussions are happening as
opposed to it's sort of bubbling up
through the culture well I think there's
a responsibility for us as leaders who
to raise these issues with our
colleagues but I but I see it coming
both ways you know think things things
work a lot better if if they bubble up
right it's but it's but I think it's
perfectly fine for us to say hey have
you thought about this and and it does
start conversations you know I mean on
on a variety of difficult issues here at
MIT and also with the brode we were
talking about this before you know our
president or Eric you know puts out a
very resourceful
am I to clarify yeah puts out an
extremely thoughtful note about a
difficult subject which you know that
that actually generates a lot of
conversation not only among our
community but among our alums and
actually well-built well beyond our
community in terms of the feedback that
we get but so so like I said it I think
it has to come in all levels in small
ways I and I've taught for 27 years mi
t--'s intra Bioforce right one of the
sessions is devoted to like your biology
in society we look at genome editing and
other things and we devote one of these
freshman classes to it and I think we
could probably go further you could ask
should problem sense right should each
problem set includes something that has
social implications it should get woven
in more right yeah probably we have to
figure out how to do it well we have to
do in a way that challenges people to
think freshly about it and argue about
it and is that something that has been
in the course in the 27 years you've
taught me
of course about 12 years now okay and
it's done I do it as a case method
discussion it's not a lecture
right I put up a few things and then we
engage in a full room discussion and
sometimes you know I've had 500 students
in the class but you know discussion
well it is but but it but people get
really really it's the it's the most
active discussion in the entire year
because you know people's just open up
to the challenges and and you get people
who disagree and it's great and
sometimes a large room is really good
because you'll take people you'll get
people who'll take an unpopular minority
position and then have to defend it and
and people who realized that there was
some challenge in something that they
said it's I love it and it's part of it
and I think we'll probably increasingly
see more of this embedded in the
curriculum right right you know it's
tougher in in say calculus but otherwise
okay hopefully all those people in math
will move over to biology like all right
there I could go on for a long time but
open it up to all of you just a reminder
please come to one of the microphones
and introduce yourself when you ask your
question and don't be shy come on yeah
you don't need to raise your hand you
can just condition yeah all right so I'm
Josh I'm a fourth year undergrad you're
a senior what are you studying
I'm studying robotics cool cool relevant
to stuff you're talking about so I think
you might ask maybe a pretty basic
question so bear with me a bit but so
we've just been discussing the whole
time that we have as scientists
engineers a responsibility for the
consequences of our research and how
it's used but we also let off with was
that some of the magic of basic research
is that we don't necessarily know where
it will lead or what the consequence
where that will be isn't there a
contradiction there and given that both
of you have been engaged in this really
fundamental research throughout your
whole careers are you confident that
that has it will leave the world better
than you found it and if you are where
is that confidence come from MIT
students are tough so there's no
contradiction I think the fact that we
don't know where it's gonna lead and
that it can lead to such amazingly good
things is the source of the
responsibility because we know it might
not lead to those things so they go
together if we could predict what the
consequences were we just shut down the
research that was going to end up being
on balance bad but we can't because of
this miracle machine we don't know where
it's gonna go which means when you give
birth to something you're responsible
too for it for shaping where it goes you
know the people who thought about
nuclear energy didn't think about about
nuclear physics didn't necessarily think
about bombs but when they had to build
bombs in World War two they felt they
then had a lifelong responsibility to
attend to making sure we didn't blow
ourselves up with bombs they they are
part and parcel of each other that the
unpredictability of the technology
means you have lifelong responsibility
so then you ask are we confident it's
going to be used for unbalance good I am
but only because at heart I'm an
optimist that you can get people to see
that but it takes a lot of work I don't
think it's a theorem that it happens I
don't think it happens without a
tremendous amount of work I think it
takes a lot of moral persuasion I think
it takes a lot of argument to happen and
I agree that on any given year it could
go wrong and it could go wrong badly and
that's a real risk and it just means we
have to work really really really hard
I'm an optimist because I think I think
people most people want the world to be
a better place but it is not easy
because it doesn't take us doesn't take
a large group of people who want to
weaponize something to make it really
really hard and in the 1950s and 1960s
the things we were dealing with with
nuclear weapons they were pretty easy to
detect as you move down to chemical
weapons biological weapons AI weapons
they become almost impossible to detect
and so the new ones that are gonna keep
us in check or gonna have to be strong
and strong international norms that
countries don't do certain things but we
did sign treaties like that and
shockingly they did stick that's why I
care a lot about the existence of norms
and it bothers me when we break norms
because norms keep us in check sometimes
I think that that's kind of the
weaponized uses but you know there are
these other things that that could just
displace jobs there I count
optimistically and I think much more
confidently on the fact that there is a
young generation of people who come
along who want to fix the world and they
will find ways to fix the world I don't
think there it's a theorem that AI has
to displace work I think there that's
that's a downhill kind of thing that's
flowing with the energy that people are
going to come in and figure out how to
use it for good but we need to inspire
people to feel like that's part of the
job and so as teachers universities you
know whether this happens in the right
way is going to be a direct function of
how many people we inspire and how many
people we bring up with that sense of
responsibility if you lose those things
if you lose norms if you lose sense of
responsibility and I'll just add to that
I mean the very fact that we have to
keep after these discoveries and make
sure they get used well make sure they
get deployed well I mean it's part of
the reason that Eric and I are not doing
as much of our own research now as we
have done in the past
I mean we've both taken on you know a
considerable amount of government
service but also you know advisory you
know many many advisory councils for
scientific societies and for the
government to to ponder these things and
put out thoughtful reports and and and
and go out and talk about them and do
events like this a lot in order to raise
these issues so so there there is a big
responsibility that those who create
these things really have to be
responsible for continuing to guide them
in the in the right direction good
question yeah come on folks
so I was curious about when you talked
about like bring up these ethical
dilemmas and ethical issues and how a
lot of times people defer on them and
I'm taking a bioethics class right now
and what I found interesting was there
was a specific case talked brought up
about the institutional review boards
and I was curious what exactly does that
role of like ethical dilemma really
actually play in the greater sense
because if people defer on so many
values and especially as you said with
like communication and technology
bringing people both closer together but
also revealing a lot of these
differences how do we further like
reconcile these differences and how can
these kind of values be like brought
together and how can there be like a
consensus formed whatsoever if it's so
diverse and different which is both
something that we triumph over but also
something that kind of creates that
divide well start with that toss it over
to you so I'm yeah so they institutional
review board at MIT is is under my
office and one of the things that we've
done this year is is add social
scientists and humanik you - to that or
so because these issues are arising and
we felt that it was really important
that we get those voices into the
discussion so so it's a it's a it's an
ongoing situation but and we're already
seeing it but that's the kind of action
we've taken to to start to move in that
direction of handling these these really
difficult issues when you got
differences you go to two different
outcomes you can yell at each other and
go to your corners and harden your
differences or you have differences
amongst people who say ok if you see
this so differently I got to understand
what you're thinking and I got to inform
myself about about how you could
possibly believe that and
what I see around here at its best is
people understand why you believe that
and say I think you're weighing that too
much yes that could be but I don't think
that's the likely outcome but I now have
to acknowledge that that's a possibility
and I've had to suddenly become more
nuanced so I worry about does the world
go to its corners or does the world move
toward the middle they're not gonna
blend they're not gonna give up on those
differences
it bothers me no end that we are seeing
social discourse go in this fashion of
polarization polarization there is no
good outcome to polarization things are
hard we have to grapple with things
there are no easy solutions to anything
in science certainly no way to get the
benefits of science there are no easy
solutions to economics there are no easy
solutions to politics
diversity is not a nice Nostrum
diversity is essential to actually
figure out how to wind our way through a
solution and I think modeling discourse
as wimpy as it might sound to people who
don't understand the power of it is some
of its one of the most important things
that we have to have as a country is the
ability to have discourse between people
who disagree in good faith it's a great
question
Maria what was the was there something
that sparked the addition of social
scientists and humanists into the IRB
well it was it was just these
discussions were coming up and you know
we just looked at it and said well you
know we we've got to get some more
discussion going in in these groups so
that was what that was what drove it so
and you've got community members on an
IRB - yeah which is really such a
brilliant innovation as there might have
been the time you'd think you just want
scientists on the IR because they
understand yeah but they only understand
a certain bit of it and is that
something that MIT does that is not done
everywhere having community members on
IR B's and
think that's a general requirement from
medicine or medicine medicine may not be
another thing medicine requires at least
one community member we don't have a
medical school but we we certainly do
interact with you know clinicians all
right maybe I'm a Brody actually oh hey
how are you doing at the breath I'm a
project coordinator with the McArthur
group awesome
so actually building on that question
about the expansion of the IRB and
including social scientists and
humanists and tying it back to early on
in the conversation when we were talking
about how the miracle machine kind of
came about by this unconventional path
of rather than government laboratories
introducing academia and industry and
other groups to bring technological
development as we move towards ethical
questions and technology do you think
that's going to exclusively kind of be
the tone of this discussion that it's
the responsibility of each individual
member involved or do you think that
will add two new additions and growths
of the miracle machine and do youth what
kind of groups do you think will be
involved in that growth of it's going to
happen that way well hopefully a lot of
people are gonna be involved in this
conversation I mean I I frankly I
frankly do expect the government to get
involved and in in some of these areas
the government should get involved and
the question is how does the government
get involved in the right way okay and
and so you know the the goal is gonna be
and will be a part of that discussion
here many many many more people than you
know the two of us here but but just to
make sure that that we preserve what's
great about the miracle machine I mean
actually our discussions you know with
with a lot of folks in DC including a
lot of folks who you wouldn't think
would would be viewing the conversation
this way is like they they realize what
a mayor of America's innovation
ecosystem has brought
to this country and and and they don't
want it ruined on their watch and and so
you know there there has to be a way to
get a sufficient number of voices
involved in this so that you can have a
rational conversation to to say let's
let's keep what's great about this let's
evolve it right and let's not break it
all so people take initiatives to create
groups during the period when we had a
cold war there was the Pugwash
conferences and the positions against
nuclear war i wouldn't be shocked to see
i'd be thrilled to see around this
community people begin to organize the
societies that are gonna help debate
these questions about AI many others i
think there are many many forms there's
the government for sure and then there's
individual initiative all these groups
that take responsibility to do things
started by some small group of often
students who feel like that's what the
generation has to do while we're letting
people screw up their courage one one
issue that I know his comp is a is a
question of especially cooperating with
China and and given that they have not
always adhere to these norms so how does
how do you how does one grapple with
that tension that you want to both be
able to collaborate and partner with as
wide a group of people as possible and
you have some places where there are
these very legitimate concerns about how
that information is going to be used
about IP theft about all sorts of issues
yeah well I actually I was just on the
phone with the Pentagon before I came
over here talking about these issues so
we you know we China has learned a lot
from us we actually have a lot
learn from China in certain areas and
and you know these these issues of IP
theft are their real the you know the
the easy thing to say is that anything
on a university campus is just open
research and so we publish it and so we
shouldn't be concerned about but but the
the fact of the matter is you know and
and if it's sensitive classify it and
then we're all done okay however there
are there are there's research being
done in labs all over the world where
any one part of it might be perfectly
reasonable and open but if you took
several things together and combined it
it could be very detrimental and and so
so it it's it's really a case of you
know we need to we need to have all
countries obeying international norms
okay for data use data release and
responsible use of information and and
so you know part of this happens because
people in different countries they want
to publish their papers and the best
journals right and so so to publish in
the best journals there has to be a
certain amount of transparency in terms
of discussion of your methods and you
know making your raw data available
making your programs available that you
you know did this analysis for and and
so so so you know reviewers have a role
to play in this the journals have a role
to play in this actually some of this is
going to be done diplomatically there's
a role in that but but basically I think
it's a matter that we've we've got to
get everybody to play by a set of
established rules and and if we do that
then we can all learn from each other
and continue to call
and what do people don't play by a set
of established rules well then then
things were gonna change in terms of
access I mean if if one country doesn't
and you have international norms about
this G ostracized right but that
requires rule-based international order
do we have that right now I mean do we
have the ability to it did you know it's
and it's not just uniquely United States
I think we were seeing much more of a
migration from the rule based
international order to our countries
simply exerting power because they can
sew interlocking systems that were put
in place sound in the short run you know
weak the long run may be very strong and
the long run our best defense with China
may be in thankful men with China levels
best defense is sort of collaboration
essentially well in well essentially
countries that actually benefit from
each other tend not to go to war with
each other right and so making it in
people's enlightened self interests but
then you have to be thinking about long
term self interests not your short-term
self-interest right I think you have
more faith and people's enlightened
self-interest than I do
do you have an alternative fine then I'm
a stick mind to stick with my until
you've got an alternative well so yeah
Jason dear I'm a night science
journalism fellow from The Associated
Press school yeah I'm from San Francisco
and I lived there for 23 years and
watched as the city really changed as
city leaders gave away a lot of public
resources to the tech companies and you
know now firemen and policemen and
teachers can't live there it's become
really an island of the wealthy and now
I live here and I'm seeing kind of
similar indications around MIT of
you-know-whats
similar types of things that are
happening with the new Life Sciences
buildings that are being built around
campus and I'm wondering if MIT is
looking to the west coast and the
mistakes that were made out there in
planning and allowing kind of companies
to come in influence the planning and
development of the city to the detriment
of a lot of people who live there and if
MIT or is working with Cambridge Ernie
if the community here to kind of help
ease the transition that I see going on
around campus and this absolutely yeah
that's a big part of the discussion so
how so first of all MIT wouldn't be
building any of those buildings in
Kendall Square if it if it wasn't if the
plan wasn't approved by the Cambridge
City Council so so there's there's been
a lot of interaction with the city of
Cambridge in terms of you know what has
to happen in terms of affordable housing
and providing internet for neighborhoods
etc etc etc and and there's a another
area where the called Volpe which is
kind of across the other side of the
Marriott which which MIT also received
the bid to develop and and you know
there's again there's plans going on for
how this is going to affect the local
community and what are we gonna do in
terms of housing you know for people
there but but these you know these
discussions are are ongoing and you know
Cambridge the Cambridge City Council is
is extremely involved you know there's a
lot of people who spend a lot of time on
that so these you know there's a there's
a lot going on in terms of negotiations
and you know we have to live here with
this community and and actually MIT was
was awarded the Volpe site because of
our experience of working with the
Cambridge
community so if they had given it to
another developer there would be a far
less of an understanding of the
sensitivities you know I mean MIT kind
of has you know a sense of what these
neighborhoods need to be you know we
want our we want our students and
faculty to you know be able to live in
this neighborhood and live nearby and
well and interestingly I mean you know a
number of years probably 10 years ago
now there was a plan for you know
building a building for faculty housing
you know nearby campus and it just had
no traction no one wanted to live in
near campus and and now everybody wants
to live in near campus and this is
getting to be some of the you know
hottest real estate real estate going so
so there yeah and that's the point is
just who can who can live that's right
and an MIT certainly plays a role in
that because you're the reason that
companies are coming and building here
is because of the access to talent and
as a citizen of Cambridge I think it's
good that MIT is thinking hard about it
and is responsible but it's really our
responsibility as the city government
citizens to have a city government that
thinks about how do we use the tax
revenues that come out of the city from
all these companies that are here to
guarantee affordable housing and when I
look at it I don't yet see but this is
not a Mighty's issue this is our City
Council's issue the formula that will
say corporate real estate taxes will
funnel into some kind of affordable
housing so that we can achieve the mix
when we want you know I'm no expert on
this but I see we're gonna set aside
something that will be affordable
housing for some period of time what I
don't see is a sustainable formula that
will keep a balance but what I do
believe is like the folks around MIT are
smart enough and think enough about
systems and economics and other things
that our City Council could benefit
from people saying how do we build this
as an organic sustainable ongoing thing
that keeps our community mixed and if
they needed those questions answered
they could probably come here sorry if
they needed those questions probably
come here yes but they probably need the
questions answered but like with much in
the miracle machine it probably starts
with students and and faculty who say oh
I see a better way to do this I see a
need for municipalities to be able to
strike balances and to be creative about
it and the effect won't just be on
Cambridge I mean many ideas come out of
this community ideas about Affordable
Care Act's and many other things I think
the idea about how you engineer
government systems so that they work
better for everybody is part of the
product of a place like MIT and Harvard
and and when we say it's a product of an
RIT in and a Harvard it's a product of
people who just decide they're gonna
pull together and do it so if you're
bothered by this and you're in this
community go organize a study group and
get some economists and figure out why
don't we have why don't we well because
I actually ask this question a lot I'm
so yeah what are you doing about it
yeah and I've written a lot about it way
to turn that around I've written a lot
of it and I guess that's why I asked is
because you know seeing it from the
other coast and we were talking about
the divide earlier you know were you
notice that not to divide but the
differences I guess is how you want to
spin it but yeah but but no I just
thought it was interesting coming here
from the west coast having seen the real
devastation that a lot of the kind of
policies that the city has made the
decisions that they've made in
conjunction with technology industry you
know many are fueled by graduates of
this university and many of the other
great universities in our country and
just you guys are having this discussion
tonight which is great and since I've
been here I think MIT has been it's been
something I've been hearing from the
professors and students and talks about
talk about the effects of the work and
the innovations here and what they have
but I think there's still a lot more to
be learned in terms of the effects on on
the cities where a lot of these
innovations are
of the changes that are occurring
you have special superpowers also to
contribute to this so I'm I'm not joking
around and saying things happen because
people care about them you obviously
care about the problem you're
knowledgeable about the problem you know
I think you'll find people who are eager
to help but it takes leadership Thanks
am i right and remembering that the
development does include set aside for
specifically I think MIT projects are
doing a very good job of it I'm much
more concerned of do we have a large
formula on the larger scale I think MIT
is not the locus of right right I just
that was my memory I just didn't know
that was I think those projects are well
far out right hi my name is Roni I'm a
third year undergrad in the computer
science department and I had just a
general question about life balance so
you spoke so we have kind of these
things that we see where there's like
billions of dollars being invested into
like the biotechnology industry but if
you look at things like the biological
weapons convention which is like
supposed to keep us safe from these
bioweapons it's like critically
underfunded and it's also always at a
budget deficit but then also the fact
that we're seeing a lack of investment
into researchers just how do we balance
like this investment in in creating new
technologies and really supporting those
industries while also making sure that
we don't lose like that we actually
invest in preparedness and in the same
kind of balancing way like how do we
make sure that we are supporting these
like norms but also regulating them in
an efficient way
like from an actually government like
top-down way without telling you to stop
doing your research yeah so I mean these
these discussions are just going on
constantly and and I mean on that the
bio side you know that so I you know
part part of the challenge that we we
run into when the kind of the bioterror
side is that there isn't a whole lot of
expertise on that in the pentagon so
they they know how to make the next big
plane or you
the next big ship and they know a whole
lot less about what they ought to be
investing in in terms of what you know
the the bioterror hazards are and in
fact I don't know if you remember it ash
Carter when he was Secretary of Defense
brought up a whole group from the
Pentagon it all spent time here and
abroad
you know educating themselves on on what
these risks were so that the the
Pentagon could plan better for them and
and that's you know so so that that is
an ongoing thing and actually out at
Lincoln lab which which I oversee which
is you know they're they're investing
more in biology as well I mean there's
there's really it turns out there's
really really interesting work in this
sphere and and it's based on infectious
diseases and and it's a and it's
fundamental research that's actually
excellent and and and actually people in
the life science areas don't think about
this as a you know possible career path
but it's you know there's there's a
great you know social motivation to you
know kind of get involved in that kind
of work and and it's actually very very
interesting in state-of-the-art research
as well so I so I think we're gonna be
seeing more in that area actually I
agree one of the last reports that PCAST
worked on was essentially on these
questions of bioweapons and there were
some in the Department of Defense who
inclined in the short term to say well
shouldn't we just classify all this
stuff we had to kind of explain that
just wasn't gonna happen because most of
it the 95 percent of applause
was going on in the open scientific
community and even to us tried to
classify it the rest of the world was
doing it wasn't gonna happen so we took
the position that we were gonna need to
use the technology that could be used
offensively to be able to rapidly build
defense
as needed we had to get incredibly good
at defeating a bio weapon and and
rapidly vaccinating against violin etc
etc we said we weren't gonna get to
practice on my own attack we're gonna
have to practice on natural disease and
that there was an there was a there was
a nice alignment that if we wanted to
provide biosecurity as a matter of
national defence we really had to be
investing hard until hidden with natural
outbreaks and I think that's probably
the right answer there is that the
technology is we're going to have to get
really good and we're just can't do it
by saving will hide against natural
diseases and we can't rip it up against
their natural defence budget as well
defence budget more broadly you're
asking about public goods private goods
it's easy to get investments in
companies biotech billions of dollars
you want investments in these
conventions and these things that
protect us those are public goods
they're not going to get the investment
the private investors and therefore we
need a country that believes in the
importance of public goods it again
bothers me when I when I hear people say
oh you know we don't want government to
do things there's some things you can't
do but by government the government is
just the expression of people saying
what do what is our common needs and our
common good that can't be solved by an
investor so I'm glad you're raising it
the answer is continually continuingly
to argue for the importance of
investment in public goods thank you
thank you
you want to ask one on the way out you
could it's okay PhD student in computer
science and my question is about
changing research cultures so
fundamentally like these ethics
questions are interdisciplinary and they
like you said they require social
scientists and humanists and
methodologies and thinking from the
humanities but it's not clear to me that
current scientific disciplines really
appreciate and value interdisciplinary
research and i and i mean i think it cuz
it makes sense because there are these
norms and ways to benchmark success and
accomplishment that are kind of baked in
to these established fields like in
machine learning for example which is
what i work in there are these confident
top conferences and you're kind of
expected to publish in many of them and
and there are things that they look for
and that they accept that are not really
not exactly encouraging or appreciative
of interdisciplinary methods and so I
guess those leaders in your fields how
do you think about changing the like
what's the best way to kind of start
changing research cultures to be aware
and appreciative of different things
besides what has commonly led to success
in those fields yeah what you know we're
spending so much time talking about that
you know we just announced the College
of Computing where we have to do what
you just said in order for this to
succeed so and and this it will succeed
we will not fail at this but but but
we're gonna you know when we get
assessments of individuals you know in
certain fields people look at certain
things and you you have to be you have
to be really smart about how you do your
assessments so I mean the most important
thing that we do as faculty at MIT is we
it in in faculty development we we
attract and
and then we promote and we retain and we
train and and and if we just go by
traditional stovepipes we're not going
to be able to evolve the kind of
interdisciplinary work that you're
talking about that's so essential so so
you've you know you you've got to get
people who are experienced in the
different fields and and they've all got
to kind of get together and you know
serve on essentially serve on the
committee's that do these evaluations so
that you know you could you could get
somebody writing a negative letter you
know about your work because it's
missing this piece but of course they
don't understand this whole piece but
you know then you have evaluations over
here of people who understand that and
you know I you know a really enlightened
group will look at that and say well
it's it's got all the pieces that we
need so this is this is a matter of
ongoing interest and it's gonna be it's
gonna be tested in real time starting
next September so in the short term it's
very frustrating that people have their
boundaries and and expectations if you
integrate over a somewhat longer period
so much the exciting stuff occurs at
boundaries those early people who were
doing stuff at boundaries later in their
careers when they're highly successful
having pioneered this new thing that was
at the boundary get to tell the stories
about other papers were turned down and
their grants were turned down and and
they do that with this you know both
smug satisfaction and still a little bit
of an edge but that is how progress
happens is most of the interesting stuff
is at new interfaces that haven't been
explored and you shouldn't be too
discouraged by that there is some value
in people defining these disciplines and
if you're interested in working at the
boundaries of disciplines you should you
should know that the story usually works
out okay
just have to be more stubborn good luck
we probably have time for one or two
more questions that's great coffee today
my name's Katherine Clark I'm an
associate professor of French studies
here and my training is in history and I
wonder so there have been all this talk
about computation at MIT in the new
college and in talking about reworking
the Gir s why aren't we talking about
having a gir in ethics or in ethics
requirements for our students just to
make sure that an expertise in science
and technology in their fields is going
hand in hand with an expertise or not
expertise but even just a an awareness
of how to have these debates and how to
frame them and discussions with
humanists happening in their
undergraduate training so so there
certainly has been discussion about
ethics for a gir I mean there's also
been discussions about project-based
learning for a gir computation for a gir
statistics for a gir diversity for a gia
climate change for G so and then if that
was the case you'd have maybe six years
required course yes so I'm so probably
the the best way to move forward on this
is is not to make it a requirement but
to but to put courses out there that are
easily findable and easily available and
people will get attracted to those
courses and they are being attracted to
those courses but there's another
interesting possibility which is build
it in yeah that that there's this notion
I guess there's a professor to Harvard
I'm forgetting our name right
now who has been pushing embedded ethics
it might be that creating a gir in
ethics would also be less effective
because it would be walled off and
however you'd feel like they have to
take the castor oil whereas if you said
you know every course should have
embedded ethics relevant to its field
then people might say Oh ethics is not a
separate thing ethics is part of the
thing that might be a really interesting
movement yes certainly certainly in the
in the college of computation the donor
Stephen Schwarzman made it very clear
from the beginning that he was he was
interested in having ethics be a part of
the curriculum so I think we're gonna
see this thank you all for being here my
name is Michael Simon's I used to work
in the Department of undergrad here the
teaching and learning lab I wonder you
know for all three panelists will get
Seth included but in terms of your own
things outside of your specialty biology
and math and very universe universe and
grindin lenses and did you you know
inspiration from other areas such as
literature poetry nature and how number
one was any of that part of your
upbringing and did that inspire you in
your field and do you see people that
have that did that provide value to you
and maybe the answer's no I just do math
or I just do you know particle physics
I'll tell you what I did so I was I was
pretty as I said pretty focused on being
a space scientist and that's what I did
but I
actually did a fellowship at Radcliffe
for a year and and I was I was in the
class drew faust when she was Dean of
radcliffe's decided to start bringing
scientists into Radcliffe and and I was
like one of the first people that she
recruited certainly in the first class
and and that year I spent I read every
book on the New York Times bestseller
list
that year because you had to or else you
couldn't if you went to lunch you had
nothing to say right had to I culture
required yeah and it was jus actually
tells the story that yeah I mean for me
I got the liberal arts education that I
didn't afford myself earlier in my
office I read books growing up don't get
me wrong but I really gave myself the
liberal education that I you know denied
myself more broadly so that I could
become a scientist but it it actually I
made me a much better scientist because
you know I
there were poets there and social
scientists and and and to be able to
have to be able to explain my work to
people like that and see how they
explain their work I mean just really
opened my eyes as to the way that you
really need to think to communicate with
other people who or who are not
scientists or engineers and so it you
know it you know helped me immensely to
to get where I am today
mm-hmm so I wasn't as focused as you
were for me I was really focused it's
just amazing so just what influential
things they were there's a 1964-65
World's Fair in New York and my mom took
me to that 13 times and cheap
entertainment
well I was in Brooklyn his Queens it
wasn't like infinitely far but boy it
opened my eyes to the fact that there
was a world
that there which is my corner Brooklyn
you might not have known and it was
really quite amazing when I was an
undergraduate I was a student at
Princeton I took John McPhee's course I
don't know how many of you know John
McPhee but an amazing nonfiction writer
he taught a course called the literature
effect on the non-fiction writing and
it's influenced all my scientific
writing when I write papers I still have
John McPhee's editorial voice in my head
I wrote for three years for the daily
newspaper and daily journalism was an
amazingly powerful thing because I think
as a as a professor you are in the
business of communicating you
communicate in your class you can
indicate in scientific papers and in
scientific scientific meetings and I
think about those experiences and how
they've shaped me and I would credit
them with a non-trivial portion of
credit for whatever success I've had is
learning those things that I never
learned in a science classroom and I'm
just yours making me think about what
things influenced me there was an
amazing Renaissance architecture course
I took that for the first time I
understood how it is that art develops
art is not just stuff art is a
conversation over time and to watch our
Renaissance architecture develop over
the course of several hundred years was
you know just like I open for me to
understand that there were those
structures and all those things end up
having an effect on the way I do science
and so I think all of us are very
influenced then getting people exposed
to things you never know what it'll be
but I can still you know in my mind
walking around the World's Fair from 64
65 and it was it was like pretty
influential so you want to think about
how you expose people to things I sort
of feel like my entire career is being
exposed to different things and then
having the freedom to get obsessed about
it and then move on to something else
but in high school I read essays by a
biologist named Lewis Thomas oh yeah
and yeah lives of a cell but it was it
was columns that you wrote either for
JAMA or for the New England Journal I
can't I'm not I don't remember which but
that had a big influence on me I knew I
didn't want to be a bench scientist but
that I wanted to be involved in and win
science but you know I wasn't still M
I have no musical affinity I am obsessed
with music so I spent the first four
years of my career as a music critic
primarily so I could go to concerts for
free also how I wrote a book about the
Red Sox because I want to go to playoff
games for free yeah so for me I feel
like my my the great the most exciting
thing I think journalism is the best
career anyone could ever have and the
most exciting thing about it is that it
gives one the freedom to find something
that's exciting and instead of main to
go through the Stations of the Cross you
just get to go to the best people in
that area and say spend a lot of time
with me and teach you everything you
know and that's incredible so I think
that about does if there's unless anyone
has one last question please well will
everyone please join me in in really
thanking
you
[Applause]